this is the jocko underground podcast
number three
with echo charles and me jaco willink
and joining us as the first guest ever
on the jocko underground podcast is
believe it or not dave burke good deal
good evening echo good evening good
evening dave
so if you're new to the jocko
underground podcast
this is a
a a podcast that complements the regular
jocko podcast it's available if you join
the jocko underground which you can do
by going to jockonunderground.com
look
we've we're doing this for a few reasons
first off most important the jackal
podcast will remain
as it is
that is free and available to the world
that's the goal
we always want it to be free and
available to as many people as possible
that's what we're doing
but
we do have to be ready for some
contingencies there is there is
censorship happening right now in the
world
right from social media companies to
traditional media companies
everything's at risk could pod class
could podcast platforms be at risk yes
they could
so
we have to do a little contingency
planning look and we've been fine but
there is risk the platforms have control
and they can de-platform
right which is a scary thing
and we've seen it happen
sometimes deservedly so but that's a big
question and debate is who gets to
decide who deserves or not right
so
we don't like that
so we gotta have attention to we would
be fools not to have a contingency plan
in case something like that happen also
we don't want to have sponsors other
than things that we make and we use and
we own
that's what we talk about so
i guess you have to put up with those at
the end of the jackal podcast because
we're going to talk about some of that
stuff
the other thing is we also want to have
a better closer connections with some of
the people that are really in the game
because
when we started this out
we were able to kind of respond to
everybody that reached out and that
we pretty quickly
maybe after a year we couldn't really it
was just too much so that's what we're
doing
so anyways what's the topic of the day
let's get to it topic of the day we just
recorded a podcast on the marine corps
field manual
the marine corps field manual which is
called competing now
that's why dave's
getting
to be the first guest
or getting getting or being roped into
being the first guest
so
there's a there's a movie there will be
blood have you ever seen this movie yeah
have you ever seen it echo charles right
now
wait there will be blood there will be
blood yeah yeah uh what's his name
daniel day-lewis
yeah so
daniel day-lewis he plays an oil man
right and he's kind of a ruthless oil
man
and he
just runs things and ruthless
businessman and doesn't care and makes
things happen and takes advantage of
situations and
it's but it's a great movie
there's one part
in that movie where he's talking to
his brother which is actually not really
his brother which you find out in the
movie spoiler alert sorry too late he's
talking to a guy that's an imposter is
it do you still have to say spoiler
alert if you're talking about a movie
that's 20 years old or are you clear hot
it's considerate to say okay spoilers
before you spoil it yeah okay okay
because it alerts people yeah you're
about to
spoil the thing so he's talking to
someone that is his brother allegedly
anyways he says this line he says
he says
i've i have a competition in me
i want no one else to succeed
i hate most people
and the brother replies he says that
part of me is gone
working and not succeeding
all my failures have left me where i
just don't care
and then
daniel which is the character that's
played by daniel day-lewis says well if
it's in me it's in you meaning i'm your
brother and if it's in me this level of
competition if it's in me it's in you
and then he says there's times where i
look at people and i see nothing more
worth liking so he's obviously like a
not a nice guy
but that lo i remember the first time i
saw that line
i have a competition in me i want no one
else to succeed i remember kind of
sort of relating to that statement a
little bit
and i still
i still kind of do
because
i have this strange
like competitive thing
inside of me
that is very hard to subdue
and i know i've i've said this to
ashland front sometimes i've been like
hey
you know why i'm up at four o'clock in
the morning because i can't stop
thinking about what we need to do to win
that's where that's what i'm doing
that's what i'm thinking about
so
you know and we started talking about
this a little bit on the podcast but
dave i i know that competition was
inherent
in your old job what how has competition
evolved for you how much of that state
when you hear when you hear you know i i
have a competition of me i want no one
else to succeed
did you ever think that
do you still think that where's it at
for you
i guess we're coming right out of the
gate here hey this is the underground
totally man so
a hundred percent
and i guess the evolution question can
come back in a minute where does that
evolve i absolutely i absolutely
understand that i couldn't tell you when
in my life but
definitely younger definitely in a less
mature place than i am now
some natural sense of
not just hating to lose and hating to
lose
hating to be outdone by other people and
i just
even at a young age like i understand
that comment now that character that is
a that that character is a at a unique
level that i don't think i've ever
gotten to
but yeah i mean of course i understand
that and i think there's an inherent
thing
of
for me like the competition with myself
is i hated not being good at stuff i
hated failing at things i hated not
being able to do things that i thought i
should be able to do and then if other
people were able to do it it bothered me
drove me nuts
there was an absolute inherent
competition in my previous job anybody
in the military i think has that top gun
i don't know if it's any different than
anywhere else but it's definitely there
a top gun for sure but when you talk
about the evolution of that
and i'm not implying that i didn't know
that before but that was a that was the
first place that i really understood
that the competition
there which is there
because what we were trying to do was so
important outside of the organization is
the first real time in my military
experience where i was part of a unit or
a squadron or a place that whose real
responsibility was outside
you know all through training when you
get into a fighter squadron you kind of
feel like your squadron is the center of
the universe and what you do for your
squadron is for your squadron
and at top gun what you're doing is
actually for everybody else so that
competition i think the maturity of me
kind of moving past wanting other people
to to be successful or not wanting to be
successful top gun breeds a lot of
competition but it's always geared
towards making you better so you can be
better for other people and that i think
helps with the evolution
whatever dna whatever gene is in there
of what he said there's that's inside me
and has been forever
uh
he's a unique character and obviously
they they portray him in that way as a
ruthless guy and i know the movie and i
remember it vividly and what he go the
links he goes to
but
that sentence that saying
i understand that there's a there's a
weird thing when i saw this movie for
the first time
he i i i really i was totally into the
movie and then towards the end of the
movie or at the end of the movie
i i just didn't get it because he ends
up this alcoholic guy that's kind of
acting like an idiot and he ends up
doing he's just it just and i said to
myself i remember watching it going wait
a second no one that's that much of a
control freak that likes to win that
much would ever go down this trap where
they just lose control and become an
alcoholic
i have to admit i don't know i don't i
don't remember when that movie came out
but i
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to
jacounderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance at
jacounderground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then
we will see you
mobilized
underground